[Applaudissements]
non le déni qui qualifie wild animals a
apporté quelque chose
évidemment l'audience oui mais ça après
ça prend le temps de s'installer et se
dire ils ont il ya une fantaisie les
nouveautés et un peu d'intelligence et
d'autres candidats du bac mais moi j'y
joue pas tous en même temps on va
commencer par caroline on met le délit
mag sais rien en fait c'est rien au
moins le mag d'avant on aimait ou on
n'aime pas mais il y avait un parti pris
le problème c'est que là ya plus de
parti pris dont qui s'y retrouve alors
devant on va se regarder quelques images
du daily mail que ça tombe bien regarder
n'est quelques neuf accords et nemesis
ferme ta gueule
je suis né
la question qu'on est en droit de se
poser c'est qu'on a changé la formule
parce qu'elle était jugée peut-être un
peu trop belle et la bête est lancée par
l'ong gérés c'est la même formule
moi je pense leur problème c'est un
problème des positionnements évidemment
hésité dans des cibles très jeunes qui
étaient trop jeunes ils ont voulu
élargir mais élargir avec l'académie des
neuf qui est un peu ringard je pense
qu'on peut élargir en faisant des choses
a plu actuel mais j'y vois là ils ont
quand même juste prix à risque
donc je pense qu'ils ont eu raison
puisque les pires des risques ce n'est
pas là pas en prendre
et puis on verra ce qui se passera il
faut lancer les temps on va parler des
nouveautés après midi pour moi ils ont
fait trois erreurs sur leurs trois
programmes phares c'est à dire que sur
l'académie de neuf tu n'es pas à 19h
clairement c'est un programme pour le
midi sur le délit mag
ils ont mis deux amateurs à la tête je
parle pas de karima charni qui est très
très bonne
benoît et capucine tu as juste envie de
tirer une balle quand tu les regardes et
les vacances des anges qui était
jusqu'alors programme qui marche et b
ils ont essayé de faire un mix entre les
ch'tis entre n'importe quel tel arrêté
pour faire un beau but bulgare ou alors
juste les orges encore une petite